- What up, vlog?
I like the camera angle here at Budin.
This meeting I had with
an incredible couple
around their dog training
business is lights out.
Really valuable for a lot of you.
Sorry I'm losing my
voice here a little bit.
Check it.
Check it out.
And pass this one on.
Because this is really relevant
for ton of your entrepreneurial friends.
(upbeat music)
What's been the biggest change
from when you guys kind
of came across my stuff?
- [Kaelin] I would say for me, personally,
content.
I've been up until now
like selfish with the content.
Like I don't want to give
too much information out.
Because every single dog
that I've worked with,
I've seen results.
100%.
- That's incredible.
- So.
I haven't wanted to give out that content.
- [Gary] I see.
- And then after listening to you.
- [Gary] You thought
it was a secret sauce.
- Yes, exactly.
So, I'm like, if I'm going
to give this out for free.
Why would anyone hire me?
Why would anybody pay?
- But it works the reverse.
- Almost $200 an hour.
Total reverse.
After listening to you I'm
like he gives out everything.
And people still.
He's giving you everything you need.
People still want to work with you
with their unique business.
- [Gary] Sure.
Because there's always
- Stuff.
- [Gary] And as much as you learn,
there's always the nuances of the details.
- Exactly.
- Plus just the fact that
sometimes people just want
to pay back somebody
that's done right by them.
Like if we designed
$1000 website of logos,
you would much rather
hire Vayner media to do
that for you than somebody you
might have used in San Diego.
- For sure.
- It's how it works.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
So that's been the biggest thing for me.
For sure.
I've seen from you after
listening to Gary is patience.
He had like zero patience.
So right before we
started listening to you,
I actually reached out
to Danielle Bernstein.
Do you know who that is?
She has the blog We Wore What,
was on Forbes 30 under 30,
because she was looking for a dog trainer.
- [Michael] She posted an Instastory.
- Yeah, so I reached out to her.
And she flew me out here.
Mainly because she's like
I interviewed all these
other dog trainers.
Nobody was normal.
So she's like this girl looks normal.
I'm going to fly her out.
So after working with her.
I would say.
So I took a week off, worked
with her, stayed with her,
helped her introduce
her puppy to other dog.
And just have that transition smoothly.
After that for
about a month and a half
the business declined.
Because I took a week off.
And this was right before
we started listening to you.
And so Michael of course,
was like, oh my gosh.
This wasn't worth it.
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- What the hell is happening?
- [Gary] I'm empathetic.
- I thought this was gonna be huge.
And then once he started to listen to you,
he's like patience, patience.
It's not about the present.
Don't be looking at the present.
When we stopped focusing
at every single day.
Oh my god we're not
selling like a package,
you know, this person didn't convert,
when we just looked at the bigger picture.
Like the content, just keep
doing, trust in the process.
- It's brand versus sales.
It's just so big.
It's so big.
It's, um, I'm just, you know--
People struggle.
And I'm empathic.
I'm competitive.
I didn't always have.
People are like oh it's
easy when you have it.
It's not that.
It's that it just doesn't make any sense
to look at your life in a six week period.
When your life is much
longer than six weeks.
To me the biggest disconnect is people's,
you know I always say your
ambition versus your actions.
If you wanna build something.
You guys aren't working
for Bank of America
or Vayner media, or, you know, McDonald's.
You're working for yourselves.
And when you wanna do that,
like it doesn't make
sense not to be patient.
You want something so big.
I don't think everybody understands
how big it is to be able
to live life on your own.
In your control and how you do it.
And so if you're asking the
universe for such a thing.
Of course, it should be worse and harder,
and longer and grindier and difficult.
Of course!
- [Kaelin & Michael] Yeah.
- Ya know?
That's the thing I need
to find a better way
to articulate.
Which is do you actually
understand what you're asking for?
Do you understand that you're
asking to live a top 1% life
in a 7.7 billion person world?
If you then wrap your head around
what you're actually aspiring to do.
Well, then all of a
sudden all the bull shit
that comes along with it makes
a hell of a lot more sense.
Everybody thinks they're entitled to it.
- [Michael] Just short term thinking.
- Yeah.
I lose on a daily basis everyday.
Everyday I'm losing.
On the daily basis, ya know?
But I think I'm winning
on the decade basis.
It's cool, makes me happy.
You been here all day?
Anything interesting?
Say hello to anybody
or they all been busy?
- [Kaelin] Everybody.
Every single person on your team.
- Good.
- [Kaelin] It's been amazing.
- It's been fun?
- [Kaelin] Yeah!
- Oh, so fun.
We've gotten a lot of good advice.
- And you've spent good,
obviously you came out here.
Do you guys spend time in New York?
- [Kaelin] Yeah, I train
some dogs in New York.
So there's a lot of people
that reach out to me.
Because of that one influencer out here
that's like you know, she
trains Danielle's dogs.
I need her.
And they wait every two
months for me to come out.
So I started coming out
here six months ago.
So since then I've come
out every two months.
And there's always more
and more dogs to train.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- Yeah, so fun.
- So that's how you
monetize your business?
The training, is there
anything above and beyond that?
That's more scalable?
- The training's the
business, local in San Diego.
And then occasionally people in New York.
And then a personal brand,
she just wrote a book.
More like a business
card, just credibility.
- Expensive business card.
- [Gary] Of course.
You guys self published it?
- Yes.
- [Gary] That's why it's expensive.
- [Kaelin & Michael] Yeah.
- You just want to be
known as the best dog--
- [Kaelin] I started
this business a year ago.
A year and a half ago.
- Why?
Because you knew you had a knack?
- I always wanted to be a veterinarian.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So I had an internship
at a vet hospital.
And with everything
medical, there's politics.
And so that just like
broke my heart to see.
- [Gary] You're like fuck.
- This is not want to do.
- [Gary] You're like nobody
cares about the animals.
- I was devastated.
Because ever since I was three years old
I wanted to be a vet.
- [Gary] It's the same
thing every teacher,
every politician,
everything that goes into
something bureaucratic.
- So it was never like I have
to be a professional dog trainer.
Nothing.
It was just something resorted back to
what am I passionate about.
Fostering dogs, being involved in rescues,
and connecting with dogs.
I just knew that I always
had this special connection with dogs.
And I can communicate to owners
this dog is doing this because of this.
So I was giving advice to a
friends among like rescues.
And soon I became the go
to trainer at rescues.
- It's so funny the way you described
that's the same way I feel about business.
I always know what the other pieces are
that create the thing.
Which is how you thought
it about it, right?
- [Kaelin] Exactly.
- Dog's peeing because
you're doing this on food,
or the relationship.
- [Kaelin] And I can see that.
- So interesting.
- [Kaelin] The owners can't.
- I get it.
- You see the pieces
of the business puzzle
that other people don't see.
- [Gary] 100%
- Yeah, totally.
So from that, just
everybody asking me advice.
I'm like I could make
a living off of this.
Giving my advice and
I just used everything
that I've learned.
- [Gary] So where are you
putting out content now?
Intagram?
- [Michael] Facebook and youtube.
- Just started YouTube channel.
- [Michael] Snapchat a little bit.
- [Gary] What kind, like a vlog style?
- Not quite.
- [Gary] How to, like
little pieces of content?
- Pieces of content.
So like training sessions
like an hour long.
- [Gary] Have you thought
about doing a call in podcast show?
Like Ask Gary Vee?
- We want to do an ask the trainer show.
- I think you would kill that.
Like the amount of people
that would call you
to a google voice number.
Again, like I do with about business,
you're like look, I'm not there.
So I don't know what's Snuffy's doing.
But the three cliche things I see
when a dog is tearing the fence,
is you've got them on a leash too much,
she's eating the wrong kind of food,
do you have a second dog?
Like if you can, the reason I'm successful
is because I can see the pieces.
I know the 47 patterns
that they normally are.
I can do that.
The reason I can still do
Vayner media and other things is
surely if I can get more details
than I can 100% get it done.
You might not be able to
answer everything every time.
But you might be able to
help eight out of 10 people.
I would highly recommend doing a podcast.
Highly, and I would highly recommend
doing a asking you questions.
That's the whole show.
You have to do nothing.
You have to have some
audience, go on Instagram live,
put up phone numbers,
pick the phone numbers.
I mean you've seen ask Gary Vee, I assume.
It's not super hard.
- [Kaelin] Yeah.
- It would work.
- Instagram live do you think?
- [Gary] You need to get
the phone numbers, right?
So whether it's Facebook
live or Instagram live,
I don't know where you're audience is.
You need to be able to pick
some phone calls, numbers,
because you don't have a switch desk.
So you need to have a phone,
speaker phone, or however you do it.
This is my way, there's
probably smarter or better ways.
But you need to just pick phone numbers.
And be like hey, Karen from Kansas City,
what's your question?
Because you don't want them calling like,
or maybe you do want a switchboard.
I don't fucking know.
I mean, I don't know how
you guys do it in San Diego.
But, you know bottom line
is you wanna get a show
where you record it and
for 30 minutes, 20 minutes,
you answer three to five questions.
And I think most
knowledgeable professionals--
time to go--
- -most knowledgeable professionals
should do an ask format show right now
on Facebook or in podcast form
or from Google.
Because Q and A besides
interviewing somebody,
Q and A is the easiest
way to create content
instead of creating it yourself.
You know the whole document versus create?
Maybe you don't want
to be reality TV stars
and document your whole day.
So if you don't want to go that route.
You know, my whole thing is just start.
And what hold everybody back is creation.
Which is why document over
create became such a big thing.
But not everybody wants to
put be on camera all the time.
So the next version of document
over create is document, Q and A, create.
The Q and A's the middle one.
The Q and A's the way for you
to produce unbelievable content.
And you don't have to do anything.
You just have to answer four questions
which you know how to do.
The biggest reason
people aren't successful
is they don't actually know the answers.
They're playing the part.
There's a lot of dog trainers
that are trying to be
celebrity dog trainers
on Instagram right now.
That don't know what the
fuck they're talking about.
- [Kaelin] Oh yeah.
I know.
- Same way is physical trainers,
same way as business gurus,
wine experts, sneaker heads,
there's a whole lot of
fucking faking going on.
But if you actually have the goods?
Q and A, you know why?
You can show your skills on the spot.
You're not scared of anything.
You know why all these
fuckers don't do Q and A?
They want to control the message.
They don't have the fucking answer.
Q and A, you're on the spot.
The reason I only want to do Q and A is
that's where I get to show my strength.
- [Kaelin] Yeah, totally.
- Cool.
I gotta go.
- [Kaelin] Awesome!
- [Gary] Leave your three cents.
I gotta go.
(soothing jazz music)